oh hello everybody I'm multiple Navy AK
and this is top five ah love is in the
air happy Valentine's Day in the spirit
of the season we're counting down the
top five best Disney animated movie
company check out my twitter at awesome
underscore Walter later tonight and
tomorrow because I will be putting up a
poll for you guys to vote on about who
your favorite Disney animated movie
couple is romance is one of Disney's
trademarks they've been telling love
stories in their films since the
beginning
and while times have change you can bet
that there's almost always a romantic
story at the heart of a lot of their
animated movie before the credits roll
we get a couple that will live happily
ever after
but which of those couples work the best
let's face it they haven't all been
winners and in plenty of earlier films
only one of them was a completely drawn
character while the other was just there
however there are also more than enough
Disney Power couples that made the grade
these are the top 5 best Disney animated
movie cover number 5 lady and Tramp from
lady in the Tramp so I felt obligated to
put these two on there a lot of the
honorable mentions came close but these
two were just too iconic to leave off
the list
lady is a cocker spaniel who lives with
her affectionate owner however
everything changes when they have a baby
the new parents leave on a short trip
and have Aunt Sarah take care of the
house this leads to several
misunderstandings and results in lady
out on the run a neighborhood stray
named tramp saved lady from an attack by
bigger dogs then shows her the carefree
life he leaves the main region lady and
Tramp are on this list is because of
this iconic scene
[Music]
on demanding the night we'll leave it
it's one of the most well known and
imitated movie kisses of all time it's
been parodied for decades now this movie
came out in 1955 1955 so that moment has
absolutely withstood the test of time
these two characters are decently strong
for an animated movie of the time period
and definitely fill the others void lady
is the pampered protected pet while
Tramp is the wild but good-hearted
strick by the end of the film ladies
owners adopt tramp and they have a few
puppies together well I don't think the
movie is all that great or an absolute
Disney classic it's undeniable that
these two pooches are still recognizable
all these years later go ahead and get
some spaghetti with your Valentine I'll
be here when you get back number 4
aladdin and Jasmine in Aladdin a whole
new world is reason enough to put them
near the top 5 but there is more when
poor young chief Aladdin finds a lamp in
the cave of wonder he releases the
all-powerful genie and with him three
wishes pining for the affection of
Princess Jasmine is Aladdin's main
concern but when Jafar the evil Royal
vizier to the Sultan takes the land for
himself
Aladdin must come up with a way to set
things right and save the kingdom of
Agrabah aladdin and Jasmine have a
decently basic set up for their
relationship streetrat attracted to a
princess the princess feels
overprotected and ventures out among the
common people they meet and you can see
where it's going but it's done so well
and with the added twist of the genie
helping out Aladdin it makes it special
enough about you I know that talked
about it she's right and the hair day I
anything pick a feature Princess Jasmine
you're very wonderful magnificent
glorious I'm sure emotional punctual
sorry a beautiful nice recovery Aladdin
is a young unwilling hero with a good
sense of right and wrong but when it
comes to Jasmine he's willing to bend
the rules just to be around her Jasmine
herself is a great complement to Aladdin
because she doesn't take any crap she's
willing to call him out when need be
Jasmine also fights back against afar
and has her own motivation being her
future in Aladdin isn't
the cherry on top of the sundae the
relationship feels earned and the two
together worked well for the story and
yeah a whole new work
[Music]
from number four to number three
Rapunzel and Flynn Rider entangled I
guess they're making tangled into a
Disney Channel animated show is anyone
looking forward to that years ago
Princess Rapunzel was born with special
regenerative and use giving powers
through her golden hair she was
kidnapped as a baby by the death fearing
mother Gothel and raised in an isolated
tower so her kidnapper could continue to
live well beyond her years by Rapunzel's
18th birthday the kingdom's most-wanted
bandits Flynn Rider hides out in the
tower and it's captured by the long-lost
princess the to make a deal where
Rapunzel can finally leave the tower as
Flynn introduces her to a world cheese
ever known
I know Flynn's real name is Eugene
Mitchell bird but I'm just calling in
Flint this is definitely the most
comedic duo on the list and that's why
they rank so high up tangled is really
funny the fluid and quick animation that
give life to their movements and
expressions in combination with many
more and Zachary Levi is compatible and
energetic voices make for a couple that
are as unique as they are amusing rookie
it sucks to come for me
stay calm it can probably smell fear the
physical comedy with these two present
in this film is very enjoyable and the
relationship develops at a pace slower
than most other Disney animated film
granted by the end they're still married
in blah blah blah but it feels more
natural Flynn has a witty presence that
when mixed with Rapunzel's more curious
nature creates a chemistry that is just
fun to watch two spots left number two
Carl and Ellie's Frederickson in up
Pixar is dizzy now it counts Carl and
Ellie Frederickson always dreamed of
moving to the exotic paradise fall after
a long married life Ellie passes away
just when Carl had planned their trip a
few years later he decides to go there
by himself by tying thousands of
balloons to his house as it floats
towards his destination Carl is a grumpy
old man who doesn't talk to many people
anymore so when a boy named Russell is
discovered on his porch after the house
has already taken off Carl has to
interact with him as they explore the
foreign land ten minutes that's all it
took if you've seen up I don't even have
to explain this to you you just know
just mention it to someone the first ten
minutes ago it's that powerful we get to
see in full Elian Carl's relationship
from them as bright-eyed kids to them
getting married to trying to have kids
not being able I'm sorry Ellie is the
adventurous one she's really the
motivation for the entire movie we get a
great look at her personality as she
gets older and we see how she brings the
uptight Carl out of his shell you know
you don't talk very much I like you Wow
when Ellie needs Carl he's always there
for her too knowing just the right thing
to do even when she's at her lowest
point
[Music]
while their story seems tragic their
life together is shown as a happy one
and that's reality there are highs and
lows and we don't always get to do
everything we want with our time here it
can serve as a great reminder to do what
you can while you can this relationship
is authentic it tugs at your
heartstrings for a reason there's a lot
to emotionally unpack here all that and
only 10 minutes over the years Disney
has put together many couples in many
movies not all the best ones could fit
into the top five so before we get to
number one here are some honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best disney animated
movie couple is Belle and the Beast in
Beauty and the Beast it would have been
very difficult to legitimize choosing
anything else's number one an entire
castle is cursed after its Prince turns
away an old woman the prince himself is
transformed into a hideous beast and can
only change back after discovering true
love years later Belle a smart and
beautiful young woman it's taken
prisoner by the beef after saving her
father as time goes on the hot-tempered
beast begins falling for his prisoner
and Belle slowly does the same getting
the way of breaking the spell as Gaston
and a horde of angry villagers after
they realized a dangerous beast lived so
close to their village I hadn't seen
Beauty and the Beast in quite a while
and it holds up extremely well from the
music to the animation to the character
work and voice acting Beauty and the
Beast fires on all cylinders the story
feels timeless and it all has to do with
Beast and Belle Belle is very smart and
no pushover from the first time we see
here she doesn't fit in where she lives
and is a bit of an outcast with her
father she's also not a long-lost
princess Belle is just an independent
lady who is living life her way her
bravery when rescuing her father also
shows that she has the courage to
overcome her own fears now the Beast is
very interesting he's a guy who's lived
half his life as a monstrous figure and
has become on the inside what he looks
like on the outside
he's hopeless at the point when we first
see him and has forgotten how to
interact with people outside his castle
holding Belle prisoner isn't exactly the
most romantic way to fall in love but
Belle appeals to his human side and
eventually brings it out when Belle
discovers who the Beast really is she
also finds someone she could have never
found anywhere else
he has tweeted strange finding you can
change learning he was wrong
as for the live-action versions
we'll see what happens with the animated
film being nominated for Best Picture at
the Oscars and all it has a lot to live
up to you in terms of the original films
legacy and its enduring fan base are you
excited or just nervous to see this one
we're only a month away Disney's old
legacy continues in animated form as I'm
sure the studio has many more classic
tales both love stories and not to tell
in the future I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite Disney
animated movie couple what do you want
me to cover next in the show leave a
comment and let me know make sure you
check out awesome comics from yesterday
where we asked is the Lego Batman movie
better than Batman V Superman follow me
on Twitter at awesome underscore Walter
to take part in more polls about what I
may cover in the future come back next
week for a new episode of top 5 happy
Valentine's Day
[Music]
[Applause]
you